I'm getting a bunch of human teeth in
the mail for beauty reasons I recently
learned that you can buy human teeth off
the internet but if you really want to
take it up a notch and I do you can get
jewelry made from human teeth rings
necklaces earrings bracelets we're
talking actual came from inside
somebody's mouth T a great place the
order human teeth jewelry is Etsy you
find a lot of handmade jewelry on Etsy
made of human teeth
I just bought a necklace it's a very
tasteful minimal tooth pendant they have
a genuine human molar ring I have to buy
it
stud earrings and each one is a tooth my
favorite thing about this tooth necklace
is in comic sans font
it says creepy and very spooky with like
ten exclamation points I found what may
be the world's most terrifying bracelet
this is definitely gonna give me
nightmares but I gotta buy it just cuz I
got to see it in person I've ordered a
wide variety of human teeth jewelry
gonna wait for it to come in the mail
and then we're gonna see what it looks
like in person all my teeth have arrived
in the mail let's touch some human teeth
from strangers it's so cute and yet I
know inside is teeth here's my tooth
definitely tooth so
it's so weird to touch oh my god I mean
you can touch your own teeth and I feel
like you're not really getting the full
experience of like grasping you can't
grasp it in your hands oh I regret
ordering this one warning this is about
to be upsetting so this is like a mouse
bangle and it's supposed to look like
gums my hand is rejecting this my hand
is like no please don't put this on what
if I put it on and I can't get it off
Bravo to whoever made this take this in
for your nightmares oh hopeful pull this
one is interesting comes in a pretty
little B Agee was very tasteful
arrangement of teeth very elegant my
last box of tooth jewelry came in this
box shaped like a casket what if there
was just a tiny dead body in here this
is straight-up a tiny coffin this is a
necklace of many teeth this is a tooth
necklace with wings
you could wear it like this actually
oops now it's stuck to my head
do you like dangly little earrings with
teeth on them very minimalist tooth
dangle earrings get ready for it it's a
molar ring oh I'm engaged to a dentist
think of all the foods that this chewed
I'm gathering up on my tooth Jewelry
should go see if I can get some people
to try it on this one is just so
disturbing that I don't even want to
look at it I want to like hide it in a
bag somewhere we're going to be looking
at some jewelry I'm so nervous I don't
know why this is a nice tooth are these
real yeah this is also have they been
sanitized this was in someone's mouth
the tooth fairy
this is her side hustle this wasn't
someone's mouth you can't help but
wonder where these came from
there's a [ __ ] diamond engraved in
this one would you wear it Oh totally do
you want me to get on one knee no I'm
proposing to you oh okay I would be
honored okay this is gonna get stuck
oh the ring is really cute it's good I
like there a lot as hell Essie
understated do you not like feel the
soul of the person when you're holding I
don't even feel my soul it's delicate
tooth necklace at first I'm like oh this
is so gorgeous and let's I remember like
user tea I knew that Ke$ha was like into
something like this I could get into it
like a nose ring no no too much no come
on
you never
no it just throws me off because it
looks like it's made to look like gum
freaking me out still what do you think
I like that I like that versus a
necklace I also have no style I think
it's cool that people are willing to
like use any material possible to make
something so beautiful if you get the
opportunity to hold a human tooth
I recommend it it's cool nothing is too
weird to be sold on the internet I think
is my biggest lesson just like for
different people
oh do you like my ring it came from a
stranger's mouth